nor says she was born in 1958 that's 36
years before a parted ended in South
Africa when the governing African
National Congress took power in 1994
politicians promised to address racial
disparities in land ownership services
and housing Nori is still waiting for
her free Brick House built by the
government my family stays here in this
house it is not strong and it can
collapse at any time
there are people who have received Free
Housing from the state andisa Gil is one
of them she said goodbye to her Mud
House 2 years ago I'm not happy this
house because it's very very
small but now I'm so happy because I've
got a big
house I'm so happy now local officials
say nearly half the people in this W in
the Eastern C Province now live in
proper structures if you have ever
stayed in a mat house
you do not know what really you will do
during the rainy season you know the the
house might fall we used to have
disasters here where houses were falling
and we used to have people who have to
be uh placed in in community halls and
now we no longer have those because
people are we are trying by all means to
speed up the process there are other
challenges unemployment and Service
delivery people used to get water from a
reservoir but the pump was stolen more
than four years ago and hasn't been
replaced and until Services improve they
now have to use the share
Taps some people choose to leave rural
areas to find opportunities in towns and
cities many of them end up staying in
informal settlements where electricity
is illegally connected to their Shacks
which then catch fire that's what
happened
here the Eastern Cape is the birthplace
of several prominent politicians
including Nelson Mandela but Millions
here are still waiting for that better
life they were promised at Independence
nearly 30 years ago har matasa aler
Eastern Cape South
Africa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer